one of the research theme leaders for
the uh causal inference
theme venue okay
so thank you for having me speak so i'm
presenting the
theme on cultural influence of the fawzi
new institute i'm very excited to be
part of this great team
of people actually from both east coast
and west coast you can see the photos my
team so
in the interest of time i won't go
through them but um
the names from co-leading this is
professor shah from mit
so the uh plan
for this theme is really design
experimentation to infer causal
relationships and also work with
observational data to infer the
aggregated potential outcomes and
hypothetical explanation in particular
we're interested in high dimensional
covariates dealing with depend data with
network inference interference for
causal inference
and related is through graphical models
and
synthetic controls reinforcement
learning and also checking assumptions
using data in observational studies so
that's where um
we um position to work on
and for the rest of the talk i'd like to
share one project
my group just finished and in the
reign of causal inference
so this is we call stable discovery
interval subgroupware calibration
and it's really again um effort of a
group of collaborators
and two young very talented scientists
leading the project
rus uh dvd from my group and also johnny
kovacs with martin reinwright
and yanshu tong who is actually the last
tripod postdoc still with us in berkeley
and the two senior colleagues are david
madigan from north eastern myself and
also we have two members from the group
britain and mia and also a physician
scientist joining us
kevin oops
so this is a project really try to work
on precision medicine
it's defined by cdc as genes behavior
environment
that affect our health and we want the
interventions and treatment diagnosis to
be catered to individuals or at least
subgroups
not just for the whole population in
particular
our work is addressing precision
medicine for drugs
that how do we figure out whether the
drug is effective
traditionally fda pay attention to
average treatment in fact but now the
field is moving to heterogeneous
treatment in fact really try to address
precision medicine problems
in particular we have access to data
from clinical trial about 20 years ago
something is um anti-inflammatory drug
called
wheel ox so wheel ox was one of the
so-called non-selective
anti-inflammatory drugs
that but it can increase the risk of gi
events like ulcers and bleeding
and also found to might not be so good
for cardiovascular
health and um however it's kind of new
and um people thought might be better
than the nouns like one so the
targets more specific enzymes um
or proteins than the selective nsaid
which
is the control in this study so the
trial started
1990 and um
merck put it out and 204 and there's
kind of a little reversal
try to say that maybe can return to
market
what we aiming to do because overall has
been proven that it's not good for the
whole population
or the broader whatever under the study
but we're looking for some
groups that maybe can kind of control
the
feedbacks control the drawbacks at the
same time
make it useful for people and we take
this predictive stable interval approach
as i said this is about 8000 patients
they're not just
healthy people they're actually patients
with rheumatoid arthritis
and recruited from 300 centers in 22
countries and the control arm is another
older drug called
naproxen and you can see that
relative naproxen the gi event um
we all wheelocks seem to be better but
for the um magic cardiovascular event
it's worse this is just some basic
notation for the
name and rubin framework we assume a
super population and we have
id observation both the covers and the
randomization mechanism ti and the two
potential outcomes coming from a
superpopulation
and we have this is randomized trials
traditionally people interested in every
treatment effect which is called tau
and recent work has been concentrated
unconditional every treatment in fact
as a way to deal with heterogeneous
treatment
your condition what you covariate and
look at the average treatment for that
group
or you can generalize that to a group
not just a particular
patients with a particular covariate or
feature x
there has been a lot of research
recently including um
people from berkeley and i work with
jessica and peter pickle and our joint
student
kuzang we divide ex learner before us
people already have something ex-learner
using
basically borrowing machine learning
from um
the supervised learning and turn the
ate now actually this is kate estimation
into
estimating the uh potential outcome
for both groups and take that uh
difference and go that way and there's
also our learner from this
um stanford and there's trillion trade
learners so i won't have time to really
give you the detail but just like this
has been uh flowery of works and many
actually tree based
uh causal trick cause of forest and bart
which is a bayesian version of train
so you have numerous number of choices
for modeling and you can combine them in
different ways so
the x and r learner you can also take
different base learners
different supervised methods have a
combinatorial number of possibilities
and
tuning parameters so it's a huge arsenal
of
estimating kate and
the problem with missing potential
outcomes that we never observed two
at the same time because usually got
randomized into one or the other
how to check a model like reality check
and we have very imbalanced data as well
because these events
happen quite rarely so our contributions
actually
stand a framework me and my group have
been developing and collaborative pcs
which i'll tell you in the next
slides from supervised learning to
cultural studies
and we introduce calibration based
predictive checks for cade models
and we depend on this particular
integral methodology because that disk
uh to use kate models we have 17 of them
actually many different ways to perturb
the data
to find stable and integral and
predictive groups for heterogeneous fact
and we found six subgroups and after we
submitted the first version of paper
actually we had access to another
studies kind of as external validation
to show that all the groups we found
still hold up
in this new study and new
to us and two groups that the other
studies smaller that just doesn't have
information to say one way or the other
neither confirm or refute our found
subgroups so the pcs firmware some of
you might have heard that i've been
talking about this for the last couple
years
it's really i think related to falsely
in the sense that
we need to do a lot more theoretical
work but right now it's a conceptual
fundamental work
they try to combine machine learning
with statistics
so predictivity very much taken from
both machine learning and statistics
machine learning made predictably at the
center
as predictability was always there in
statistics and computability very much
um taken you know made
central to data analysis by machine
learning and stability is a
generalization of
uncertainty concept to the whole entire
data science life cycle
and this is basically three components
try to bring
brian's two cultures unify stream lines
expand
on ideas and best practices from both
machine learning and statistics
so the pcs framework connects
science engineering for me data science
is both engineer and science
predictability and stability embed two
very important scientific principle
prediction and replication
and computability is a generalization of
this reach of convergence
computation computational science type
of view
in the sense that we do that care about
scalable consultation but also we want
to introduce
data inspire simulation to argument
the data we have observed
[Music]
and i started working on this path um i
think like
seven eight years the first paper i
wrote was stability with the two key
lecture
really try to connect the sample to
sample
variability of probation with two keys
robust statistics so this is very much
you know very much related to the robust
defense i did the reason i didn't use
the word
robust because robotics has a particular
meaning already instituted
it's very much the robust statistic idea
and also generalized to the whole data
science life cycle have interpretability
reproducibility and
hypothesis generation as a first step
toward causal inference
it applies to the whole data science
life cycle and recognize the
judgment calls we make every step of the
way
for example with our address here is we
already designed the data right we have
also got external validation data from
the approved study
and how do you futurize how do you take
the threshold you have different choices
and you should do the perturbation to
make sure your
conclusion is robust and what metrics
you're going to evaluate the different
subgroups and what data perturbation
going to do
right you do cross-validation and how
you set data aside
and as i said we add them looking at 17
different
kate algorithms would they give the same
results so we want to use predictability
as model checking
or reality check to screen certain
agreement then
seek stability among the ones past the
screening
and interpretation we want for stable
and
clinically meaningful subgroups so it's
easier to understand
i think that will enhance the
transferability as well
so in particular we worked on 16 binary
features actually some of them already
buying
um can binary but many we binarize so
you have a threshold problem
how to cut at older population and
younger and we
took two thresholds and studied those
and ended up with
16 binary vectors and the way we perturb
the data
is we call have 12 settings so always
set aside a test set
we don't touch and then we turn into
four fold
and then we make one fold the validation
fold within the training
and then for the three training folds we
actually also
re-split three times so we created 12
possible splits or data probations
and then we look at for each model see
this is from the
ex-learner with space learner random
forest and cross learner lasso
that you look at vertically look at the
groups
in terms of the predicted or estimated
uh heterogeneous aspects locate and cut
it
into we cut into five groups and then we
look at the
training faults and validation folds and
the model kate means you use the model
which is a random forest
underneath it and the soup
and that's the average the blue curve
and then you look at just this subgroup
and look at the name and kate means you
just do the difference of this group
and then the same for the validation
fold you can see that the lower group is
pretty stable and the second group
not so much so that indicates that maybe
you should look at
the first g1 this group seems to have a
clear benefit
for um wilds relative to uh naproxen
the two drugs
and then this is just visual we develop
something like generalized r square
but using the validation fold to to see
really how well
um the model does relate to just like
the vanilla subgroup difference it means
and then the global ate so this is
really trying to generalize something
like anova but using the test or the
validation set not that sorry
validation to have this score because
it's using the validation vote
is now between 0 and 1 as traditional r
squared but it can be
minus infinity to 1 close one is still
good
but it can get pretty bad if the model
doesn't fit very well
i mean the coefficient just adjusts the
group size so that things are more
comparable
so if you look at the 17k models
you can see that overall things don't
work that well
right a lot of them um not really much
better
than the um
it's a big spread and the validation
said you have really varied performance
sometimes
is our square was coming it's quite
negative you want to be close to one
we barely have anything close to one and
same for the
vascular event the cbt
and each data point here is remember i
have 12 data perturbation schemes
that each data project can give me one
score so
we're seeking stability again the
takeaway is that the case model do not
have good generalization
on the whole data set but the bottom
quantity-based subgroup for both events
or the top contact group for the
cardiovascular event
are radically stable and cross 17 models
but
each because remember i'm cutting based
on the estimated kate
surface so that depends on which surface
you cut
you end up with different subgroups
right the next steps are which case
models to use
to identify subgroups and how to turn
subgroup
into clinical clinically interpretable
subgroups
any questions
what we end up doing again rely on
predictability and stability
of course all this has to be done
computationally with
many parallel um it's very easy to
paralyze
so we have lots of lots of paralyzed uh
calculation to get the results
so you take a particular model m
and particular data perturbation
remember we have
12 of them and then we want to have more
standardized
measures so we can compare compare
across different models and different
perturbations
through this almost like a t statistic
using the um um
the validation asset so and we also want
to know
how big the bottom group you should take
right we have five groups and you can
just keep increasing that so i also look
at
the first bottom group put the first and
second together and so on so forth
so we have this aggregated kind of
measure for each model and each data
perturbation
through this almost like t statistic
compared with the average
treatment effect ate and they see this
subgroup is that really different
in the right direction and relative to
the average treatment effect
standardized by the standard error
so now we have 17 different models cage
model which i don't have time to tell
you the details but
it's different groups developed and then
we take the original split
and then just t statistics so each
perturbation
and each model end up with this t-score
and we list 17 of them and the first one
actually the best one for this case is
actually um
um t learner which logistic kind of base
learner
inside that and the xlr you can see most
ones
all the ones on x learners
and we did more perturbations
we did remember we fixed the fold and
then for the training folds
we did the two random mouse splits
and we also split the data based on the
enrollment time
to mimic a bit external uh validation
from the same trial but we didn't split
just randomly we split based on the time
and enrollment the patients
of course you know stratified and then
we also perturb the data based on how we
set the threshold how defined like six
year old
about being older or 65 and
also how you said bmi to cut as a base
or not
and also how do you define the outcome
there's some ambiguity
so we also perturb that to make sure
that
our conclusion doesn't depend on this
arbitrary human judgment cause we made
in the process of
kind of futurization or data cleaning
so end up with seven different
perturbations
and with these t-scores and
they're not they're comparable but not
exactly comparable because
the details of the models are very
different so we end up using the ranking
we believe is more robust to compare
this different
model performance and we end up
finding
six models which seem to be
appearing above
on top of the list
across different productions so you take
each method
and you look at seven different rankings
and look at the top ten
who gets how we have 17 of them and
these six models
tend to be consistently in the top ten
ranking using the t
statistic and actually mostly the
ex-learners which actually took
my nice surprise because this is
developed by um
my group and collaborators actually in
the beginning this is pretty culture in
the sense
in the beginning actually we didn't use
excellent for some reason
the students in the group decide not to
use x learner and now it's just for the
sake of understanding the benefit
developed by migrant collaborators
and say well why don't you guys also try
x learner since i just want to see how
it performs
it turns out to be performing really
well and the t
learner which means two trees that means
you just fit
the outcome for the treatment group and
also fit the outcome
for the control group and then do the
cross that works very well that's
also in our ex learner paper we also
find that t learner works really well
so that's what we have now we have we
finally find use predictive
screening it's kind of reflected in the
t statistics
and we also sought quite a bit on
stability
across different perturbations and
futurization
and end up with six
models
and now we basically took the ensemble
the average of
the 6k models and get an example kit
estimator
and the next step because again this is
just a continuous surface
you cut vertically you're now going to
end up with
a nice like rectangle region
in terms of your your space or easily
describable so we also have another
layer of um
algorithms the c to find interval
rectangle regions by constraining the
values of some features
we kind of allowed you can for each
decision rule we can only use three
features out of 16. otherwise
we worry about too much time to search
and it was just hard to describe so we
want simplicity and we also want
stable destroying cells
so what we end up with is um
this is just a summary right as i said
pcs is a framework my group has
developed for the last almost 10 years
and we had five
four motivating projects and now we did
three new projects which after the
framework was set in terms of the paper
published
by myself and my former student council
earlier this year so
we first went for pcs
predictability to screen models and
compare multiple models 17 of them
and multiple perturbation we have 12 of
them
and then we seek this t statistic kind
of metric
to really rank the different models
using one perturbation
and use ranking as the metric
to pull the different seven different
perturbations together so it's quite a
bit of work
and then we went for easily interval
decision rules
in terms of a cell search that each cell
can only
rely on three out of the 16
predictors or features and now we got a
clinical integral subgroups
so that's what we got we found six
groups remember we have two
events the nyproxen
is also an anti-inflammatory drug it's
an older drug
and this is the control arm so saying
reox is better doesn't mean compared
with the
the healthy people is better but this is
what um how the clinical trials done
so we found that if the patients have
his
history of gi event then vioxx
disproportionately reduced crs for
patients
also if the group of patients with
history of hypertension
and prior uses of steroids the third
group is
old age and prior to your steroids so
these three groups overlap
together they consist about 30 of the
patients in the study and the overlaps
it's about i think
uh 70 to 80 so it's there's quite a bit
overlap
no sorry about 30 i got it reversed
and then for the cardiovascular event
we have to find other three subgroups
history
of this is basically plug in your heart
artery
astro sclerosis the other group is used
is aspirin that's probably meaning that
you already um
have some blood clotting problem that's
why you're taking aspirin
because one problem we find is that uh
proxima can really um i think
clot the blood so make things worse
for people already have a blood clotting
problem that's why
i think the first merc put out the drug
from the market
and the third group is old age and male
gender
and for the the last group is this uh
star
it just actually um we validated these
groups in the test data remember was set
aside with all the perturbation that's
all done with training data
but the the the um the sixth group
we we cannot really see much in the test
data just
not no event
then we submitted the paper uh to
international state reviewed with a
special evil for our brand efforts
international prize he got last year
and um we decided to look
for external validation so even it's
randomized trials right it's the gold
standard
but as you have seen the study subjects
were not
randomly selected population eventually
the drug would be used for it's a
particular group of patients with
uh health problems and a sad famous
diet cochrane between measurement based
on rct
randomized clinical trial and benefit in
the community there's a golf which has
been much
underestimated so the different
populations very different
and one study opened
without that being david madigan have
shown
and collaborate shown that some drugs
you see different studies have
conflicting conclusions
their differences in populations and
clinical monitoring
is different who gets needed who doesn't
so all of that
can cause things not transferable from
one study to the other
so the proof study was a later study
with smaller
uh number of patients but for this
the treatment still wilds but the
control problem is placebo
so um their primary purpose is really
reduce the risk of polyps
individuals with the recent history of
these tumors so it's a different
aim but still it's relevant because you
also look at y ox
and however the trial was terminated
earlier because the high
cardiovascular toxicity and withdraw the
drought from the market even in the
beginning of this they were thinking
about putting it back to the market
so because we had a very interpretable
rules from subgroups it's very easy to
compare
otherwise the things are not very
comparable it's just more stable
and we asked do the subgroups find by
our message for the bigger study the
first study generalized to the approved
study
and the good news that mostly yes as i
mentioned earlier
four out of six subgroups show
significant heterogeneous treatment in
fact
in the approved study and the
heterogeneous tree in fact the other two
groups
cannot be confirmed or refuted there's
just no data
for the approved study
so the sixth group i have shown you you
can see with the check marks that they
are confirmed
it's not exactly validated because the
study design is different
we're comparing with a placebo here not
with another drug
and the two groups didn't get confirmed
it's because we have no evidence so it
didn't get refuted either
so this was a very nice um study
for us to confirm what we discovered
because you never know that you're
really finding things only work for the
you know people in the study but this
give us more confidence that the
subgroups hold
so to summarize this is really a
particular case study of this pcs
framework however we had to do work to
generalize
supervised learning in terms of the p
predictability
to cause your status recalibration
because you never observe
both potential outcomes and we have a
calibration-based predictive checks for
cate models
and we look at 17 different models and
12 different perturbations
to really come up with a stable and
integral methodology
to find six groups and um
the approved study it's really
a very nice confirmation of what we find
and it's really not exactly eternal
validity because the designs are
different but
it's a very strong evidence to support
the methodology and the subgroups we
find
so hope it will be useful more as a
general methodology
developed with this random trial
randomized
clinical trial data
and the two papers at my website the
first
actually have a name called vertical
data science which is really the pcs
paper
and the second paper is also there
thank you very much thanks ben
so we have uh one minute before the the
break if
anybody has questions i'm not going to
post those in the q a
otherwise um i think jesse will be
posting the
uh gather town link again there it is uh
and if you'd like
to click on that and meet up and gather
town
we can do that so we're starting again
in 15 minutes
15 minutes time
thanks very much thanks ben that was
great
thank you i guess i can hang out for 15
minutes before i have to disappear again